[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hello.
I can't speak as fast as Dan,
but I will try and do my best.
My name is Mark.
I'm a developer
advocate at YouTube.
I'm going to talk a
little bit about gaming
and then a little bit
about some new APIs
we've launched for interactivity
on our live platform.
First up, gaming on YouTube.
It turns out it's
actually pretty big.
We have a lot of gaming
content on YouTube.
We have a lot of
gamers watching content
on YouTube-- let's
play's and reviews
and live streams-- and
it's always growing.
We saw this and we
built YouTube Gaming.
We wanted to give
that content a home,
so we built this place
where all of our live
and all of our VOD
content can come together
in context that makes
sense for gamers so people
can find it and understand it.
And it just looks really slick.
So if you have not checked
out YouTube Gaming,
I encourage you to do so.
It's gaming.youtube.com.
And I mentioned live content.
And so we really
like live gaming,
especially the community that
kind of springs up around it.
The phrase we hear a lot is
it's like sitting on your couch
playing games with a friend.
When you're doing that,
you want to play with them.
You don't just want
to watch sometimes.
You want to play
with your buddy.
You want to get the controller.
And we see this too.
When it works, it works well.
We see people in like
heavy console games
like GTA, Destiny, Call of Duty.
It's a great thing to do.
The streamers love it.
The fans love it.
It can be a little
clunky to manage.
People get left out.
You have to be on your couch
in front of your console
or computer or whatever.
So there's an opportunity
here to build something
where everyone can participate.
Something that's
unique to this style
of streaming and having
a big at-scale party.
If I were to call people
up on stage versus
have people raise
their hands and so on.
So it's about scaling that
community interaction.
A great example of this is the
game Whiplash by Jackbox Games.
They actually built this game
with this use case in mind.
It supports 10,000 players.
So if I'm streaming
this game, I can
have eight people that are
playing on their phones,
but then I could have up to
this massive audience that
are participating
in this scaled way.
And they built that with a
web app and a client server
approach, but we
can actually build
these kinds of experiences
directly on top of YouTube
with our live chat system.
You can integrate with
a very lightweight API
and watch for keywords,
hashtags, prompts,
sentiment monitoring,
anything you want to do.
And then anyone who's
watching the streamer play
the game can engage
and interact and be
a part of that experience
right from either the YouTube
website or the mobile app,
because they pretty much
all support chat.
Any client except for,
I think, the TV clients.
You can jump in and chat.
We've just put together a
very basic REST API for this.
This is just a little
sample of the JSON.
There's a lot more data, but
this is really what you want.
These are the messages.
You can understand
a little deeper.
You can see if people that
are watching the stream
are donating in real time
and potentially unlock
benefits for those people.
As a lot of Youtubers
like to monetize
their content through our
fan-funding and sponsorship
programs.
You can understand a
little bit of information
about the people that are
engaging with this content
as well.
You get their display
name, their channel
ID, and understand their
relationship with the channel.
Are they a sponsor?
Are they a moderator?
Things like that.
To get their picture to put
together little experiences.
Excuse my terrible mockups
that I made in slides.
Maybe you're doing
a voting and you're
putting people's
names on the screen
and their pictures
in a face pile.
You can do leaderboards
if you have people
that are participating
in the chat
and you can actually
store the state
if you wanted to
go a little deeper
or you can just do this
all very lightweight
through the client in real time.
We made these APIs, as I said,
very simple to get started.
Youtube's API is actually
part of Google's API.
It's a question that I
get from time to time.
Any library that has that's out
there for Google's API surface
has the YouTube support in it.
YouTube accounts
or Google accounts
so if you have any
sort of integration,
you're building for Android
or any of our platforms
that support m those are YouTube
accounts as well if the user
has a YouTube channel.
And then, of course,
all this is you
can use this in any
engine and the engine
that supports it REST
calls, basically.
And that is it.
So we put this
together and we're
really excited about
being able to offer
this kind of scaled ability to
build lightweight interactions
through YouTube and to see what
kind of at -scale community
interactions we can have.
I would love to hear from anyone
that's interested in this.
Anyone who's building
for YouTube in general.
Please feel free to email
me, and then of course,
developers.google.com/youtube
as we can get started with all
that.
And I'd like to
introduce Nathan Martz.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
You.